hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba and
I'm John Humphrey we have a top reward
video requests from patron and a
youtuber Omni one Omni Omni one Omni
media Michael B who just passed 1000
subscribers Congrats
he has wonderful content sincerely mean
that he does a lot of reactions reviews
discussion videos as well so I love that
he has podcast requests for us because
he gives us the opportunity to talk deep
about a subject hand upon things I've
been up since like 6:00 in the morning
today shooting this in the afternoon and
on the road a lot it was just I'm sure
that's coming back from screen junkies
news so I seem a little bit out of it I
apologize just wanted to clarify that
instead of forcing energy this video is
a time capsule yes it is what today was
like this question is how about your
all's feelings on Disney's attitude
toward edgy risky or off brown projects
off-brand projects after the news about
Deadpool possibly being pg-13 and their
discomfort what Tyco itt's Jojo rabbit
uh well okay let's see here for that
whole thing about Deadpool potentially
being pg-13 I feel has kind of got in a
little bit thrown out of hand I feel
like that's been blown out of proportion
definitely a lot oh yeah I mean David
leach was just pretty much having a
casual conversation an interview talking
about how you know Deadpool's rated our
Disney doesn't really do rate at are I
feel like it could be pg-13 and then
suddenly all these the headlines and
articles and YouTube videos that David G
need to be rated arse as director david
leitch and netted netted uh and i think
you i don't think it would be anywhere
near as good of a quality of a product
if you did Deadpool as I'm wearing a
Deadpool shirt right now I don't think
you be anywhere near as good of a
quality project if you did Deadpool as
pg-13 obviously but you could get
creative enough to make it work somehow
be
the thing about Deadpool is that there
are so few rules you have to conform to
that they could find a way to
acknowledge it and still you know use it
for comedy basically I think you can
that's not what happening I would hate
That's not me honestly I would hate that
and by no means was david leitch
implying that it's going to be pg-13 and
i feel like that's how everyone wants to
spin it to get some cool click Beatty
you know freaking awesome story to try
to riff off of where they talk for 15
minutes about it and then and in terms
of Taika Waititi there was a Disney exec
who did come out I don't remember who it
was who said it they didn't really name
him in the article now that somebody
during some of the early screenings
there was an exec who had like a very
audible response and was concerned about
you know basically it not matching the
Disney brand and I'm not being able to
sell it based on that or turning people
off of it you know based on that well of
course of course
Jojo rabbit isn't but it's at a Fox
Searchlight yeah and and recently you
know like help with someone at Disney I
think it was Bob hire they were you know
really pretty much talking how Fox has
handled their projects as of late
oh they in have a they feel like they've
lost so much money from buying them had
they're like check-in meeting about
their stock I guess and basically why
the the stare projections basically
weren't on point he basically credited
to Fox yeah and some of the reports
basically say that that's part of it but
also you know attendance was down at
their theme parks but basically they
place the the lion's share of the blame
this quarter on Fox and I find that
interesting I mean like I feel funny
that people are freaking out about the
Jojo rabbit thing just because I mean
yeah it is a bit concerning if there is
an exec who is sort of like does this
match our brand I don't know but the
thing about Disney is that they've put
out r-rated movies under their other
subsidy companies for years and years so
like as long as they they don't have to
put the castle in front of it you know
it's a Fox Searchlight film and that's
how it
out the first trailer you know so even
though Disney acquired Fox I don't see
what really sets this apart from Miramax
or touchstone or whatever they've owned
in the past that's put out our rated
movies you know yeah but that was the
past and this is now and also in the now
I've you know like in our lifetime we
haven't seen anything so publicized of
such a merger before so like Miramax in
touch soon I feel like a lot people
didn't realize Disney owns them box
everyone's gonna be like Disney owns
them you know like that's kind of at the
forefront and that's such a big topic of
discussion in the cultural zeitgeist at
the moment it's gonna be that way for a
very long time I think especially
because Disney is the box office global
king they make I think Disney makes good
movies they make good movies I like most
of the films i watch from them and they
play it safe they do they play it safe
they make it was just as strange agent
Joestar calls it strawberry pop-tarts
yeah they make strawberry pop-tart
movies it's like you know you're gonna
get and they deliver for the most part
or at least they get enough people a to
come check it out that they make their
money back it's like risky they might
terms and do in terms of plot and let's
see how audiences will respond to this
kind of so even then they don't really
commit to the rest go out of the time I
don't think I think the fear of this is
as like as the fear coming in from the
intellectual properties right now that
like Oh blade is that going to be pg-13
Deadpool are they gonna pg-13 that
projects that are already are based
franchises that they've inherited alien
predator things of that nature are those
gonna be pg-13 now because they don't
fall under the Disney brand if there's a
Disney person who's complaining about
Jojo rabbit it doesn't fall in a Disney
brand I'm like to me sounds stupid that
sounds stupid yeah no you know what you
you inherited you know a guy you know
what you bought the whole slate on hand
where you just thinking about like x-men
you knew what you were buying one in
that article two they they flat out say
that they just didn't care about Dark
Phoenix like oh yeah well they retooled
their marketing campaign to be really
low-key and they're also really they've
got more bashing about the New Mutants
to I'm fascinated by the the whole New
Mutants situation I guess because what I
didn't realize until today is the
reshoots haven't happened yet I just
know that they've been talking about
them forever and what the purpose of
them is and that is what's really got me
curious at the moment I think I think
there's gonna show up that movie they're
not gonna they're gonna release it
anywhere that seems like just a waste
though I like just to never release it
seems like a total waste cuz they could
still make like then it's just money
down a hole but I feel like you could
get some of that back if they held it
for Disney Plus or something yeah I
think Hulu is there better I don't think
they would do Disney Plus but I think
they would do like whoo yeah put it out
somewhere yeah yeah yeah they would
benefit from that um I wouldn't be over
I think people are over freaking out a
little too much honestly I do is it's
kind of this like really hyperactive
reaction towards a couple of news
stories and whatever but they I I think
we're gonna see less Billy we're gonna
see probably less original films sure
under the Fox umbrella I think you know
they were to let off a lot of employees
and I think what dis canceled like most
of their development slate - yeah and
what Disney excels in is finding the
right movie to franchise right like
that's what they do so they're gonna
want it so if they have I don't think
they're gonna pg-13 Deadpool I highly
somebody pointed out to me literally
just yesterday that above all else what
Disney does is Disney makes money and I
think they're smart enough to know that
Deadpool is gonna make its money being
the most Deadpool it can be like they
know how to cater to fans and use that
as a tool to make money so I feel like
it would be a misstep that they could
easily see coming to make Deadpool Pete
it's already a billion-dollar franchise
yeah I mean you can't
you can't just change and it changed the
superhero game which they changed by
having Marvel you know so it's like they
have to take a cue from there yeah I
like this this attitude they've
specifically we're talking about Michael
be this attitude towards edgy riskier
off-ramp projects well they're gonna try
to they they I think I brought up at the
beginning of this this discussion that
they're aware that eyes are on them of
how they're gonna handle the Fox
properties and this whole r-rated talk
is definitely something they're aware of
as well so I highly highly doubt they're
gonna do anything to actually are just
completely swing the other way and pg-13
this [ __ ] is up I think in terms of like
risky original films that's more where
my concern goes I think that element
will be diluted Fox has been
experimental even with some films that
are such a release from Fox that are not
franchise based properties you got that
what's the Astra ad astra and I was
thinking about it with a Christian Bale
won the racing one with o4v Ferrari yeah
so you have that movie as well a -
there's a good example - it was
anihilation wasn't Fox was it but movies
like a nily are not gonna be made any
more now well and I think Fox
Searchlight is at risk of being shut
down - they already shut down one there
was some subsidiary company they shut
down but I think Fox Searchlight is
gonna be at risk of being shut down I
think that would be a pretty gross
mistake because Fox Searchlight seems to
be about the most consistent thing Fox
has and it consistently each year brings
both Awards contenders and things that
are you know at least a couple of things
that grab like I'm just been shocked
this week that ready or not it's not
even out yet but the reviews have been
great you know it's so they're able to
dish something like that out and we'll
see how that does but you know the end
of the day its box office though yeah
for sure
they make Wes Anderson and he's an
institution like they make guillermo del
toro he's an institution he's not maybe
always the biggest financial
success when he's given the gigantic
budget but I mean shape of water just
won a billion Academy Awards yeah but
for for every film that Fox Searchlight
puts out how many of those films get
garner that kind of attention box-office
wise is is pretty much my point here
like Dave if everything that's come out
that sounds like sort of negative from
the Disney side talking about Fox has
been about loss of money oh yeah so I do
think from a creator artists standpoint
yeah that's a super big bummer if they
were to lose Fox Searchlight I think
that's a really big bummer
I just don't see why the after investing
billions upon billions of dollars and
feeling like they already lost more
money they're not gonna hone in on on
properties that are not guaranteed to
beat these juggernaut hits of like if
you look at the top ten worldwide of
this year already they've had like five
or six films cross a billion dollars
this is the kind of game that are
interested in playing well yeah but I
don't at the same time I don't know if
they if that's it then I feel like
what's scarier and what they would be
smarter to do is then go in and maybe
refocus Fox Searchlight or retool it to
be more in their wheel cuz they still do
Disneynature they still it doesn't seem
like they just absolutely don't care
about anything that can't be a big
strawberry pop-tart you know but yeah I
mean if it so happens the 20 that Fox
Searchlight like hemorrhages money or
something like that like that's why I
would be worried for them but they seem
to be the most I don't know there's just
something about their business and their
like quality of output that seems to be
the most consistent thing coming over
from Fox because their franchises aren't
cutting it and they named a couple other
departments in that report that weren't
you know satisfactory or whatever I feel
like just to lose it would just be kind
of weird and random like there's such an
opportunity to turn it into something
what was the other one they lost Fox
2000 was the company that produced
hidden figures which in recent years has
given us the the most well-known names I
can think of the hate you give love time
love Simon
was pretty popular the road chip hidden
figures of course the movie joy David
O'Russell Jennifer Jennifer Lawrence
David O'Russell Alvin and the Chipmunks
the root for town's bridges spies spell
Burt film these are these I like pretty
big attached directors and pretty big
attached stars in here too so for them
to shut down that department I think
actually does say a lot I I wouldn't be
say I basically wouldn't be so concerned
about your properties that you want to
stay our right at being r-rated I don't
think you have to really worry about
that especially ones that are already a
success like Deadpool
yeah I mean there's questionable
elements about like like I don't know
how you could possibly make a predator
an alien movie without it being pg-13
rated R oh I've got some sequels to
recommend you we've yeah we've seen how
that goes and arguably the taste test
has shown that those need to stay if
we're gonna keep dredging them r-rated
they need to maintain a certain level of
menace yeah that yeah exactly I don't
know I mean I I feel like again the
solution to all of this could just be to
maybe rework what Fox is within Disney
and put those movies out under that
banner don't put the castle in front of
it cuz do they do all the Marvel movies
do they run with the Disney bumper no
tomorrow yeah it's like nowadays we just
see the Marvel bumper and that's and I
feel like in that aspect too you could
see r-rated you've blade or something
well if Marvel's willing to go there
well I think Fox working within Disney
is supposed to be just another you know
subsidiary company within there
the way Fox Searchlight is within Fox
but then also Fox with like the way
Miramax and touchstone were treated
doing the similar thing yeah I I just I
just feel like they're gonna really dial
back a lot more of the films they have
been producing oh no way I don't think
they will there it's gonna put the
Disney bumper in front of every one of
those films they're still gonna be
treated as Fox films but I think it's
gonna be certain films we're gonna want
to put that Disney bumper there oh yeah
I feel like though well yeah it's like
they'll have probably a different
relationship with
the projects that get brought in and
their say over those and also it will
probably continue the contribution to
the death of the midrange you know
thirty to sixty million dollar film does
I feel like that's also something that
maybe is kind of going away with Fox
2000 at least I don't know what the
budgets on all those movies were but
they all seem like kind of mid budget
movies and it seems like in the film
industry today what is what everybody's
gravitating towards either your Blum
House making something for five million
dollars and hoping it makes you know 200
million dollars or you're doing gigantic
things that people have to see in the
theaters and so that's what basically
worries me the most for foxes are they
just going to make it a different
version of our blockbusters and the
occasional indie films wing or are they
gonna actually keep what Fox's
sensibilities were about you know yeah I
mean I I don't feel like it'll cult
every film will ultimately go down as
this under Disney but like if someone
walks out Jojo rabbit screaming who
works within Disney and says that like
that's kind of a dumb analysis to make I
think at the same time there's like
billion people who are making these
decisions at Disney and Fox there's so
many did so many heads we don't hear
from ya you know and there's a lot more
people involved or there's the people
crunching the numbers or people making
business decisions and there's such a
large team and we haven't even heard of
half of the people's names to be honest
so and half of them are in merchandising
yeah yeah so I think the smart move to
do is you you they want they should have
the thing that keeps making them the
money they need to make and then also
have the things that are where they can
experiment my worry is that they'll lose
the experimental stuff my word is that
they'll lose a lot more of being willing
to do edgy or stuff like Jojo rabbit I'm
willing to you know tackle on subjects
such as that satire especially is a
tricky thing and I find that interesting
that it's that movie that got that
particular response from an exec because
then that makes you wonder you know is
this just somebody revealing their their
lack of understanding or satire and you
know like that's something important to
at least cultivate in the
marketplace and that's not a hugely
service genre right now as yeah like
that is kind of scary to you wonder if
that's just one random exec out of a
whole roomful of people who kind of got
it or if that's the flavor in the Disney
you know culture that is clashing with
the Fox coal they didn't even name that
did that guy did they no no they just
said one executor no I don't even know
if it's true yeah exactly it just said
one guy random person had a reaction I
think just wait and see I I feel like
they're gonna they pay attention to what
everyone's concern is and they like how
did look at how Disney runs their
properties now that we're aware of like
whenever there's a concern about
something they make changes that's the
way they do it in the back of my the
cynical voice in the back of my head
almost wonders if that's just better
marketing for Jojo you know cuz that
just makes people want to see stuff more
yeah outraged the social media voice is
the focus group you know more than test
screenings and all that they're alert
there they've always had focus groups
and now the social media is the the
focus group and they know most people
are not going to be happy if they they
stop if they tear if they take R rated
properties pg-13 them up or completely
dial back on original content not
everything can just be franchise base
I'm sure I'm sure they primarily look at
numbers but they also know the value and
mixing things up so mix things up and in
the way that a good film can make money
for being a good film you drew sure
alright guys well what's your take on
this subject leave a comment down below
you guys to subscribe to the reel
rejects click that notification bell and
make sure to check out my Kobey's
youtube channel as soon as you can
because he he's actually been on this
channel before and he's just a very
friendly guy very nice guy very
intellectual and knowledgeable dude I
think you'd really love him seriously go
check him out give make you guys